the most complex problems in our time
can be solve with simple techniques if
we are able to dream as a child I
discovered that creativity is the key to
cross from dreams to reality I learned
this from my grandmother dr. Ruth C hawa
i Jewish refugees that settled in the
heart of the Andes that is how I grew up
encouraged to see beyond any limitation
so part of my education included helping
hair.you remote indigenous communities I
chose those memories because they helped
me to understand the life outside the
city a life with a lot of possibilities
without barriers as language or culture
during those rapes my grandmother used
to recite a Kipling claim something
hidden go and find it go and look behind
the mountains something lost behind the
mountains lost and waiting for you go in
the coming years I became a medical
student one of every hundred children
born worldwide has some kind of heart
disease there is a part of this problem
I think I can solve this part of this
problem I have spent my love my life
working on the problem starts during
pregnancy the fetus needs to survive
inside the mother the survivals the
hands-on communications between the
systemic and the pulmonary blood at the
moment of breath this communications
needs to stop if doesn't close the baby
has a hole in the heart it is caused by
prematurity and genetic conditions but
what we know today is the lack of oxygen
it also is one of the causes as you can
see in the chart the frequency of this
kind of hole dramatically increase with
the altitude when you look patients with
these conditions they seem desperate to
breathe to close the hole major surgery
used to be the only solution one night
my friend Martin knows we were camping
in the Amazon region the only thing that
not burned in the fire was a green
avocado branch they came a moment of
inspiration so we used the branch as a
mold for our first invention the hole in
children's heart can be closed with it a
coil is a piece of wire wrap it onto
itself it may be don't look so fancy to
you now but that was our first
successful attempt to create a device
for this major problem in this video we
can see how a very tiny catheter takes a
coil to the heart the coil then close a
hole after that moment of inspiration
they came along a very long time of
effort developing a prototype in vitro
in vivo studies took thousands of hours
in the lab in work the coil if it works
can save lives I returned from Germany
to Bolivia think
in that wherever we go we have the
opportunity to make a difference with my
wife and partner dr. Alexandra heat we
started to see patient after Seussville
successful treating patient with our
coil we felt really enthusiastic but we
live in a place that is 12,000 feet high
and the patients there they need a
special device to solve their heart
condition the hole in altitude patient
is different because the orifice between
the arteries is larger Morse patients
cannot afford to be treat it on time and
they die the first coin could successful
treat only the health of the patients in
Bolivian the search started again we
went back to the drawing board after
many trials and with the help of my
grandmother's indigenous friends in the
mountains we obtained a new device for
Central's indigenous women told stories
by weaving complex patterns on looms and
an unexpected skill helped us for the
new device we take this traditional
metal to weaving and make a design made
by a smart material that records the
shape it seems the time the weaving
allows us to create simplest device that
not rust because it's made of only one
piece this can shape by itself into a
very complex structures by a procedure
that took decades to develop as you can
see the device enters the body through
the natural channels doctors have only
to grow the catheter through the hole or
device
spanks place itself and close the hole
we have this beautiful delivery system
that is so simple to use because it
works by itself no open surgery was
necessary
as doctors we fight with diseases that
takes a long time and effort to heal if
they do this is the child from before
after the procedure
as you can see as you can see once
device is in place the patient is 100%
healed from the start to the finish the
whole procedure takes only 30 minutes
that's very rewarding from the medical
and human point of view we are so proud
that some of our former patients are
part of our team a team thinks that
close interaction with patients that
works with us together we have only one
idea that the best solutions needs to be
simple we lost the fear to creating
something new the pad it's not easy
many obstacles arise all the time but we
receive the strength from our patients
their resilience encourage inspire or
creativity our goal is to make sure that
no child is left behind not because of
cost or access so we have to step a
foundation with one-to-one model we will
give one device for free to make sure
that every child is treated we are in
many countries now but we need to be
everywhere and this whole thing began
with one impossible idea as we'll
continue it really no child is left
behind
muchas gracias
you